[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend den Sport
hat Norbert Lehmann für Sie einen
schönen guten Abend und heute gab es im
Parlament das Highlight der
haushaltswoche
Schlagabtausch im Bundestag scharfer
Rhetorik und der Ruf noch Zusammenarbeit
bestimmen die Generaldebatte
ein Angriff mitten am Tag im Osten der
Ukraine sterben nach russischen Beschuss
mindestens 17 Menschen auf einem
Marktplatz
und zitter sieht gegen Lettland
Deutschlands Basketballer stehen im
Halbfinale der WM und lösen das
Olympia-Tickets
[Musik]
in der Generaldebatte im Bundestag hat
Kanzler Olaf Scholz den Ländern Kommunen
und Opposition ein sogenannten
deutschland-pakt vorgeschlagen das Ziel
eine rasche Modernisierung des Landes
vorm Kanzler hat aber erst einmal wie es
Tradition ist der Oppositionsführer das
Wort Friedrich Merz der Chef und sie uns
Fraktion Griff Scholz scharf an Karl
Hinterleitner berichtet
es geht heute im Bundestag um seinen
Etat wofür Kanzler Scholz und die
Regierung das Geld ausgeben dazu
eröffnet er morgen die Oppositionsführer
die Generaldebatte seine Kritik an der
Regierung grundsätzlich zentrale Ziele
erreichen Sie nicht die ganze
Herangehensweise sei falsch
[Applaus]
im Land mehrheitlich nicht mehr
mitgetragen weil die Menschen ist
einfach leid sind nur noch mit Verboten
Regulierungen und kalkulierbaren Kosten
und bürokratischen Auflagen konfrontiert
zu werden der Kanzler im Angriffsmodus
er wirft märz vor einem Popanz
aufzubauen der Oppositionsführer werde
dem Ernst der Lage nicht gerecht gleich
darauf aber appelliert Scholz an mir
Gemeinsamkeit der Parteien ich möchte
ihn deshalb ein paar vorschlagen sagen
wir einen deutschlandpackt ein
Deutschland packt der unser Land
schneller moderner und sicherer macht
Tempo statt Stillstand handeln statt
aussetzen Kooperation statt Streiterei
aus der Ampel kommt vor allem Kritik an
Friedrich Merz die FDP meint der Weg die
Regierung auch in der Klimapolitik sei
richtig es geht um die Erhaltung des
Wohlstands um Schlüsselindustrien wie
beispielsweise die Automobilindustrie
wir wollen in Richtung Klimaneutralität
aber wir wollen eben das insbesondere
durch technologieoffenheit gewährleisten
und die Grünen attackieren März scharf
für seine Äußerung von Anfang der Woche
Berlin-Kreuzberg stehen nicht für
Deutschland
eine CDU die diesen Weg geht die anfängt
zu definieren wer normal ist und wer
nicht wer Deutsch ist und wer nicht wer
dazu gehört und wer nicht die geht einen
gefährlichen Weg die Opposition von
links und rechts zeichnet ein düsteres
Bild linke und AFD sehen das Land mehr
oder weniger am Abgrund schuld sei die
Regierung
Lebensmittel
der Kinobesuch
die haben die vorher schon wenig hatten
verzweifeln und die Angst nicht mehr
über die Runden zu kommen frisst sich
immer tiefer in die Mittelschicht hinein
welches Geschlecht im Personalausweis
steht das können die Bürger entscheiden
ob sie aber in Zukunft noch die heiz-
und Stromkosten bezahlen können oder
welche Heizung sie überhaupt einbauen
dürfen das wissen sie nicht werden die
Bundesregierung ihre politischen
Schwerpunkte sind völlig entrückt es war
eine general Debatte der Gegensätze
zwischen den Parteien Uneinigkeit in der
Sache doch gleichzeitig der Aufruf des
Kanzlers zum Zusammenhalt
der Kanzler setzt also auf einen
deutschland-pakt wie reagiert die
Opposition darauf
naja überraschende Umarmung lösen hier
manchmal eine Vielzahl von Reaktionen
aus und so ist es auch mit diesen
ausgebreiteten Armen der Ampel
grundsätzlich hat sich die Union heute
offen dafür gezeigt aber natürlich
konnte sie sich auch die Chance nicht
entgehen lassen ist politisch gegen die
Regierung zu wenden das Angebot der
Ampel zeige doch vor allem deren eigene
Schwäche aus Sicht der Union ist das
ganze auch nicht unproblematisch
Friedrich Merz musste sich ja schon
dafür kritisieren lassen dass er im
Bundestag mehr Initiativen der
Bundesregierung mitgetragen als
abgelehnt hat und jetzt zu helfen in
Hand der Ampel zu werden ist selbst für
eine staatstragende Partei politisch ja
nicht das oberste Ziel wenn man in die
Union hineinhört dann hat sich da auch
eine gehörige Portion Misstrauen
angesammelt man fühlt sich bei
bisherigen Kooperationsprojekten
gelegentlich hintergangen die Union
wusste übrigens vorab nichts von diesem
Kanzler Angeboten sonst hätte März
wahrscheinlich heute einen anderen Ton
angeschlagen so aber gab es erst einmal
ein wüstes Rededuell und erst dann das
überraschende Angebote Zusammenarbeit
insofern war das heute auch ein
politisch menschliches Lehrstück danke
schön Theo für diese Einschätzung
die hohen Energiepreise machen der
deutschen Politik zunehmend Sorgen
deshalb wollen die Bundesländer die
EU-Kommission davon überzeugen einem
industriestrompreis zuzustimmen die
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
Tagen erstmals seit 2018 wieder in
Brüssel auf dem zweitägigen Treffen
unter anderem mit kommissionspräsidentin
von der Leyen geht es auch um das Thema
Migration
die IG Metall will in der Stahlindustrie
die vier Tage Woche durchsetzen das hat
die Tarifkommission beschlossen sie
fordert eine Verkürzung der
Wochenarbeitszeit von 35 auf 32 Stunden
bei vollem Lohnausgleich und 8,5% mehr
Geld die Arbeitgeber Wiesen das Umgehen
zurück der erste Verhandlungsrunde ist
für November geplant
in der Ostukraine sind bei einem
russischen Luftangriff auf einen Markt
mindestens 17 Menschen getötet worden
laut offiziellen Angaben mehr als 30
erlitten Verletzungen die Stadt
kostiantiniska liegt nahe der
Kriegsfront um der Ukraine weiter
beizustehen ist US-Außenminister blinken
heute überraschen nach Kiew gereist über
den Besuch und über den Angriff
berichtet Axel Konrad
der Angriff kommt ohne jede Vorwarnung
getroffen werden ein belebter Markt
mitten in der Stadt und umliegende
Geschäfte mindestens ein Kind ist unter
den Toten dutzende Menschen werden
verletzt unter den Trümmern werden
weitere Opfer vermutet ein Terrorakt so
der ukrainische Präsident
wir verstehen was sie tun sie haben das
in der Vergangenheit immer wieder getan
weil immer unsere Armee erfolgreich ist
nach der Kirche die Russen zivile Ziele
Infrastruktur Menschen bin auch immer
ihre Raketen erreichen können
Christian jennifer hat rund 70.000
Einwohner und liegt 50 km nördlich von
dir jetzt während die ukrainische Armee
im Süden Erfolge verbucht ist sie hier
im Osten in der Defensive
der Angriffe auf kostantinska geschieht
nur wenige Stunden nachdem der
amerikanische Außenminister blinken
überraschend in Kiel eingetroffen ist
solidaritäts besucht der vierte bereits
blinken verspricht weitere Militärhilfe
in Milliardenhöhe
wir sehen gute Fortschritte bei der
Gegenoffensive wir wollen sicher gehen
dass die Ukraine dafür alles bekommt
aber auch für die Zukunft militärisch
gerüstet ist so dass solch eine
Aggression sich nicht wiederholen wird
zwei Tage will blinken in der Ukraine
bleiben Tag 1 steht ganz im Schatten des
schrecklichen Angriffs auf Christian
tennefka
was sagt dieser folgenschwere russische
Angriff aus über die ukrainische Raketen
Abwehr
sie kann halt nicht zaubern so nah an
der Front ist es technisch fast
unmöglich Geschosse abzufangen wir
kennen das auch aus rakiff der Stadt im
Norden der Ukraine wo die Raketen und
andere Geschosse oft einschlagen bevor
der Luftalarm ausgelöst wird deswegen
ist der Schulunterricht dort jetzt unter
die Erde in die U-Bahn fällig worden in
Kiel ist die Situation etwas anders das
ist weit genug im Landesinneren der hat
die Luftabwehr ausreichend Zeit sich auf
die Geschosse einzustellen und schafft
es fast 100% der Angriffe abzuwehren in
Konstantin in konstantini konstantinika
gehen fast täglich Raketen und Geschosse
runter und sterben fast täglich ein zwei
drei Menschen das ist dort schrecklicher
kriegsalter Tag jetzt auf dem Markt mit
so vielen Toten hat die Welt einmal mehr
erfahren dass die Menschen in der
Ukraine Takt täglich in Lebensgefahr
schweben
seit Tagen leidet Südosteuropa unter
extremem Unwetter mit stark und
Dauerregen die Zahl der Toten stieg
mittlerweile auf 12
fachleute sprechen von einer Situation
ähnlich wie im Ahrtal vor zwei Jahren
nur mit einem Vielfachen der Regenmenge
zudem bewegten sich die Tiefdruckgebiete
kaum von der Stelle massive Bergketten
sorgen dafür dass ich Gewitter aufbauen
und immer wieder erneuern besonders
betroffen Bulgarien die Türkei und
Griechenland dort beginnt Oliver Flamm
mit seinem Bericht
noch immer fließt drückt brodelt das
Wasser aus den Bergen ein Damm ist
gebrochen mitten in der Nacht der Hof
von Johanna
wir haben viele tote Tiere hier und wir
haben auch ein totes Schaf bei uns
gefunden von einem Bauern weiter
oberhalb da war es noch schlimmer als
hier einer seiner vier Hirten ist dabei
ums Leben gekommen
auch ein schafskäsebetrieb in der Nähe
ist zerstört schwer vorstellbar wie es
hier weitergehen kann
der Schaden vielleicht 5 Millionen
vielleicht zehn wir haben darin fast
unsere ganze Produktion gelagert damit
der Käse noch reifen kann das ist jetzt
wohl alles kaputt das allermeiste davon
sollte nach Deutschland gehen
am schlimmsten getroffen haben die
Fluten die Hafenstadt wolhus aus allen
Richtungen kam das Wasser und riss alles
mit sich
schweres Gerät um aufzuräumen gibt es
kaum Strom um Pumpen anzutreiben gar
nicht für die Helfer ist es gefährlich
denn immer wieder setzt neuer starker
Regen ein
es ist ein riesiges Gebiet in dem die
Sturmfront gewütet hat sporadeninseln
wieskios sind betroffen aber auch die
Türkei schwere Überschwemmungen mitten
in Istanbul auch in einem
Touristengebiet im Westen wo mehrere
Menschen starben und einige noch immer
vermisst werden und auch an Bulgariens
Schwarzmeerküste haben die Unwetter
getobt im Touristenort zarevo wurden
Autos und Wohnwagen ins Meer gespült
noch immer wird nach Überlebenden
gesucht
in näher Lefki in Griechenland steht das
Wasser im Ortskern inzwischen einen
halben Meter hoch 100 Menschen sitzen
dort fest ihnen steht eine weitere
sorgenvolle Nacht bevor
und vor Ort in Griechenland ist Annette
hilsenbeck wie ist die Lage aktuell auf
was müssen sich die Menschen einstellen
ja also der Regen hat gerade wieder
eingesetzt vielleicht vor 20 Minuten um
besonders heftig und das hatte ja auch
der Wetterdienst vorhergesagt dass es in
der Nacht und am frühen Morgen zu
heftigsten Niederschlägen kommen würde
mit Mengen mit enormen Wassermengen die
noch mal jetzt dazu kommen der
Katastrophenschutz hat entsprechend auch
Warnungen rausgegeben schon seit dem
frühen Nachmittag für die nächsten 24
Stunden und für Teile auch wieder eine
Ausgangssperre in der Nacht verhängt
hier in Nähe Lewski wo ohnehin schon die
eine Brücke hier weggerissen wurde weil
ein Bach ein kleiner Bachlauf zu einem
Fluss angeschwollen ist der hier alles
mit sich gerissen hatte der auch hier
hinter mir weiter tobt wird das
natürlich irgendwie mit Sorge betrachtet
man fürchtet dass es noch größere
Schäden geben könnte und weiter unter
den Flusslauf hinunter los muss man ja
jetzt hier sagen den Flusslauf hinunter
ist ein Dorf eingeschlossen von den
Fluten da sitzen 100 Menschen fest
die müssen wohl auf dem morgen warten
bis sie evakuiert werden die Menschen
die wir hier treffen sagen alle so etwas
haben sie noch nicht erlebt und eine
weitere solche Nacht steht ihnen ja
jetzt auch noch bevor
danke schön
und nicht nur Europa wird gerade von
Wetterextremen getroffen auch im Süden
Brasilien gab es schwere Unwetter ganze
Landstriche wurden dort überschwemmt
tausende Menschen mussten aus ihren
Häusern in Sicherheit gebracht werden
allein im Bundesstaat Rio grandi du sol
hat es mindestens 27 Tote gegeben so
viele wie nie zuvor bei einem
klimaereignis sagte der Gouverneur der
Region
diese drei reiferen Herren hier die
Rolling Stones haben es wieder getan mit
Jagger Keith Richard und Ron Wood
insgesamt 235 Jahre Lebenserfahrung und
Gepäck waren im Aufnahmestudio das
Ergebnis Heck mit Diamonds ein neues
Album mit eigenen Songs das erste seit
2005 und natürlich rollt nun eine
gigantische Marketing-Kampagne an los
geht's in London Heike Petersen hat die
Details
ihre Legende lebt und sie tun richtig
was dafür ein neues Album von den
Rolling Stones Keith Richards Ronnie
wood und natürlich Mick Jagger
aufgeregte Fans seit Stunden in Londons
Bezirk nee heute kurz Mittelpunkt des
weltweiten Rock'n'Roll Cosmos
man mit 80 nicht alt und müde auf der
Couch sitzen muss
der beste Moment meines Lebens
der Bühnenshow für die neue Platte
diamonds
zehn Jahre ist bisher dass sie zuletzt
eigene Songs rausbrachten die heiße
Botschaft heute weltweit im Livestream
ihre allererste Platte bewerben sie noch
so
[Musik]
Musik Journalisten den haben wir ein
Bier gekauft und gesagt hier ist unser
Album hört mal rein und dann sind wir
raus aus dem Pub das war's
die 1962 gegründete Band ist eine der
erfolgreichsten und langlebigsten in der
Geschichte des Rock
dass sie bald alle in Musiker Rente
gehen das Gerücht begleitet die Band
schon lange doch sie tun es einfach
nicht
[Musik]
halten in unserem Alter muss irgendwie
alles an Dir in Bewegung bleiben
ein Song wurde heute schon
veröffentlicht angry der Rest dann im
Oktober
[Musik]
heute offen ob sie noch mal auf Tour
gehen
jetzt gehen wir zum anderen Auftritt zur
Basketball-WM Norbert da steht das
deutsche Team jetzt im Halbfinale
erstmals wieder seit 21 Jahren nach dem
Krimi heute Mittag in Manila gegen
Lettland ein zitter Sieg 81 zu 79 mit
einem starken Comeback von zuvor
verletzten Franz Wagner Halbfinalgegner
am Freitag die USA
kaum auszuhalten die Spannung in der
letzten Minute Deutschland in Weiß hat
eine komfortable Führung fast schon
verspielt nur noch zwei Punkte Vorsprung
und dann kann der heute Arsch
schwächelnde Kapitän deine Schröder
nicht für die Vorentscheidung sorgen nur
noch sieben Sekunden wenn David jetzt
aus der Distanzritt ist Deutschland
geschlagen das war knapp Deutschland im
Glück die lecken und tröstlich es gibt
seltenspieler wo ich wirklich wirklich
dieser Spieler es ist aber auch der
Spiel des Franz Wagner zurückgekehrt
nach Knöchel Verletzung kompensiert der
22-Jährige den schwachen Auftritt von
Schröder und wird zum Mann auch der
Mensch deutschland hat mit Erreichen des
Halbfinales auch die
Olympia-Qualifikation geschafft
die spanische fußballnationalspielerin
jennifer ernoso hat Strafanzeige gegen
Verbandspräsident Louis erstattet der
hatte sie bei der WM Siegesfeier in
Sydney unvermittelt auf dem Mund geküsst
Herr Moso hatte das unmittelbar danach
scharf kritisiert die FIFA suspendierte
daraufhin robiales der bislang aber
einen Rücktritt abgelehnt hat
am Samstag das erste von zwei wichtigen
Testspielen der DFB-Auswahl in Wolfsburg
gegen Japan zurück im Team
bvb-verteidiger Niklas süle der zuletzt
vom Bundestrainer Hansi fliegt nicht
mehr berücksichtigt worden war seit der
WM wurde er nicht mehr eingeladen der
Bundestrainer hatte Vormund Fitness des
bvb-verteidigers öffentlich kritisiert
jetzt aber ist Niklas süle zurück kann
seine 9 monatige nicht Nominierung aber
weiterhin nicht so ganz nachvollziehen
er hat mir seine beweggründet
ähm die muss sich akzeptieren die muss
ich nicht immer jetzt 1:1 verstehen
lustige Übung gerade Training kann
richtig Spaß machen
wenige Regionen auf der Welt sind so
geschichtsträchtig wie der nahosten
Jahrtausende lang kämpften die
verschiedensten Völker und die
Vorherschaft das bezeugt auch dieser
neue Fund in einer Höhle am Toten Meer
vier Schwerter knapp 2000 Jahre alt
offenbar hatten jüdischer Rebellen sie
hier versteckt für eine Revolte gegen
die römischen Besatzer die Höhle war
aber auch anderen bekannt bei den
Ausgrabungen wurden auch Hunde aus der
Jungsteinzeit entdeckt
und das sind die Lottozahlen von diesen
Mittwoch die Gewinnzahlen lauten 3 6 8
13 20 47 Superzahl ist die 2 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 55
es scheint weiter viel die Sonne mehr
dazu gleich von ist Intelli das heute
schon mal können Sie um 21:45
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf der
Nordhalbkugel war der Sommer der wärmste
überhaupt wir sehen hier zwar die
gesamte Erde aber nach Norden hin das
war ich deutlich davon ab was es bisher
in den Daten Aufzeichnungen gab und
diese Wärme war natürlich auch in den
Meeren vorhanden und ist noch
vorhandener Mittelmeer zum Beispiel
dieses Tief hier das ist Daniel und das
sorgte für diese extremen Wetter
Ereignisse in Griechenland und es wird
ja auch weiter regnen bis morgen
nachmittag ja und bei uns ist es
ziemlich ruhig oft sternklar ganz im
Süden bildet sich Nebel bei 10 bis 18
Grad im Westen also ziemlich mit Morgen
viel Sonnenschein den ganzen Tag nur
ganz im Norden gibt es einige Wolken
dazu gibt es einen leichten bis mäßigen
Ostwind und das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 31° ganz im Westen dass
sie die höchsten Werte auch nach Norden
den immer noch 30 Grad an den alten 25
Grad und die nächsten Tage bleibt es bei
diesem sehr sonnigen Wetter mit
überdurchschnittlichen Temperaturen von
26 bis 32 Grad und damit wünsche ich
Ihnen einen schönen Abend